hello there you're watching the press
preview a first look at what's on the
front pages as they
arrive in the next half hour we'll see
what's making the headlines with the
director of the demos think tank polly
mckenzie
and the pr consultant alex dean so let's
see what's on some of those front pages
now
the male's assessment of the election
results is unflinching their headline
the day boris blew up labour the eye
keeps things brief labor in turmoil they
say
the guardian has a pretty similar
headline albeit with a few more words
the financial times attributes the
conservatives success to what they call
johnson's vaccine bounce
the times thinks the results could keep
him in number 10 for a decade
the telegraph leads with the prime
minister ruling out another independence
referendum
as it remained unclear whether the snp
would retain an outright majority
at hollywood and the sheffield star is
one of many local papers across the
country
focusing on the elections in their case
the shift of the city's council from
labour
to no overall control in other news the
mirror leads with a new line of inquiry
from
police investigating the murder of pcso
julia james
and on a lighter note the sun has a
story involving chef
jamie oliver and a stolen tractor
and we're joined tonight by polly
mckenzie and alex dean good evening to
you
both well a bumper a crop of papers
covering the
election let's kick off polly with the
mail which
has this photograph of boris johnson
with a a giant inflatable version of
himself which is across many of the
papers and the headline the day boris
blew up labour
it's intriguing there's something about
this balloon looks like boris's brother
joe johnson
to me but um it was inflated in harley
pool by supporters of
boris johnson to welcome him he said he
was going to go from
jabs jabs jabs to jobs jobs jobs
and it's really you know there's no
question this is a devastating day for
the labour party
uh massive almost astonishing success
really for
a conservative party that has basically
been in power for 11 years but
has this extraordinary ability to
reinvent itself
to distance itself from both the theresa
may administration and the david cameron
administration be
completely fresh and new and to be
arguing that
changes needed change is coming which is
a narrative you'd expect from the
opposition
we're getting it from the incumbent is
our really extraordinary results
and it's because the conservative party
as i say has this ability to adapt to
changing circumstance
you know they are going to the north and
talking about public spending
and jobs in a way that you would have
seen from the labor party in the 1970s
if they can pull it off and maintain
that electoral coalition
then you know it's quite hard to see
what the labour party is going to do to
ask them certainly not on the results of
tonight is it going to happen
soon and alex after the 2019 election
boris johnson had talked about being
loaned
votes from red wall seats is it now
looking like a more permanent shift
yeah that's what a number of
commentators have been suggesting this
bout of
results um might be might lead us to
conclude that
um some of these votes are actually
indicative of a broader political shift
where the labour parties move towards a
younger more urban vote
and then losing some of their working
class rate that's actually a
a transition that isn't just about one
election it's a more long-term
move and of course the problem for them
is that no matter how much you might
like the idea of a young trendy urban
vote there aren't enough of them to
compensate for the loss of your
working-class voters and i think the
mail's got it about right here
that the prime minister has has dealt a
terrible blow to the labour party
i would say they say one thing about
that from my perspective i've both
i've fought elections i've won them and
lost them and it's a horrible thing to
happen when you
lose an election and one of the things
that kirsten is going to have to deal
with
is that he's now got hundreds of
activists and
hundreds of councillors desperately
disappointed to have been
slung out on their ear unceremoniously
um yesterday
and many of them were regarded as having
been no fault of their own
that they lost their seats very
difficult for a party to manage that
yeah let's have a look at the eye labor
in turmoil the headline
there quoting kirstalmer admitting that
he
the parties lost the trust of working
people
so who is responsible for this kirstarma
alex saying he takes full responsibility
where did it go wrong i mean one thing
that
he has done today is managed to unite
peter mandelson
and john mcdonald the left and the right
of the party uh on the fact that there
is no vision
sure no i thought i thought the mcdonald
attack was actually pretty good
basically than
if you're um if you're in opposition
then oppose um
was the the line from mcdonald and you
can't send out your activists and your
campaigners
without a clear policy message and i
think that's sort of that's going to
sting people expect a kind of corbynite
attack you're not far left enough
and people will be ready to dismiss that
the cleverer attacks now being mounted
on kieva
i think are landing more significant
blows as a result of being
a bit more reasonable than just you know
let's be a bit more
left-wing and say that if you don't
agree with us you could just push off
and join the tories
um but sarah you you used the phrase
that kierstarma used he said he wanted
to take full responsibility
which seems to extend to him taking
responsibility up to and include and not
including the point
where he takes responsibility for
anything i mean in the end it seems that
deputy heads will roll and we're going
to have a cabinet reshuffle quite a
shadow cabinet reshuffle quite soon
where kia starman moves around the chest
pieces i'm afraid one conclusion from
this episode may be
that no matter the qualities of the
individual and no matter how bad luck it
is sometimes
it's just not your turn it's just not
going to be your time
michael howard whatever other people
think of him i think would have been a
perfectly good
prime minister of this country it just
wasn't to be in the political cycle of
the day
and therefore that eminent qc did not
get to become prime minister
and wasn't leader of his party for very
long i fear that may well be the case
for kierstahler
yeah the guardian also describing labour
in turmoil after
the tories inflict huge defeats polly
when alex talks about that the timing
peter mandelson today said the two c's
were the reason here covid
and corbyn is jeremy corbyn still
genuinely a factor here
and when we're talking about coronavirus
is that the reason
why zakir stama has failed to cut
through
i think it there's no question that you
know a lockdown pandemic year has been
more difficult than uh than most in
which to make his mark as a leader
you had to oppose a bit but equally
especially in the early months of the
pandemic you couldn't just oppose that
wasn't the public mood it wasn't the
right thing
to do but of course labour's problems
are so much more deep and also so much
more complicated than that
you know you rightly ask the question
whose fault is this and there are so
many people there is
a question of what corbyn did in terms
of both factionalism
a far-left set of policies very
alienating to lots of groups of voters
there's also what the left used to
criticize is
the the way blair realigned the party
away from
working-class needs and working-class
priorities in lots of ways
and that has a legacy as well it's why
liberal democrats grew as a party
obviously that
then stalled after 2010 it's why the
greens have risen as a party lots of
those votes
went to ukip from the labour party and
have now gone on to the conservatives
and not going back
so blair has a legacy corbin has a
legacy there's what miliband did in
changing the party
there it is it's so complicated and the
problem is that that means that
every faction can say it's someone
else's fault
and what star isn't doing it seems
is pulling together with a vision and
saying
this is the thing back me or sack me
follow
this is the way the victory lies instead
he's trying to just
a bit like charles kennedy used to do in
the liberal democrat party just
be a chairman a holder together with all
of the factions
which i don't think is enough from the
leader of the political party
so a period of soul-searching but but
soul-searching doesn't
win you elections does it and the clock
is ticking for kirsten alex
that's right and i think too sarah that
one of the things he's going to
face is that as you get closer towards
an election
some people who might absolutely agree
with your ideological position
start thinking that they're going to
lose their seats and on this current
trend if these numbers were anything
like reproduced in the general election
we'd be seeing a number of labour mps
being turfed out of seats they've held
in some cases for a very long time
and at that point people think to
themselves doesn't matter how much i
i believe in you as an individual
doesn't matter how much i like you if
that's relevant at all
if you're going to lose me in my seat
then i'm going to change my position
and that's something that kiyos dharma
is going to have to face up to and think
about i mean god bless i know
polly is saying but you're actually
outgoing some if you try and blame tony
blair
for these uh results in the end the buck
stops with the leader of the party
and it has to go beyond words i think
for people to understand that he really
gets the fact
it ain't going somewhere thus far and
also
boris george johnson has campaigned very
well here
it meets some people in the media don't
like him lots of people on social media
don't like him just another reminder
that neither social media nor mainstream
media
are actually real life and they don't
determine how people vote
okay we're going to take a short pause
but don't go away because
lots more analysis are coming up it is a
prospect that will divide opinion
but could boris johnson be in downing
street for a decade we'll be discussing
that next
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
only about half a mile from the turkish
coast and
it's evident that is the boat seriously
overcrowded
this is one of the most severe viruses
in the world
i'm alex crawford and i'm skye's special
correspondent based in istanbul
that's it it got us then
a lot of action going on
[Music]
we aim to be the best and the most
trusted place
[Applause]
clearly not had very much to eat at all
a lot of them extremely thin
and very frail her arms look at her arms
i can
put my entire hand round
[Music]
this is the cocktail of drugs which the
doctors at this hospital have been
giving their coronavirus patients
made for people who want clarity in an
uncertain world
[Music]
but once it takes hold it's very very
difficult for these
firefighters to get a grip of it and get
on top of it and put it out
[Music]
i can't imagine
how much plastic is lying at the bottom
of this huge lake
getting up close and personal with a
rhino
this is what makes the job so
fantastic
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the press
preview with me polly mckenzie
and alex dean uh polly i want to turn to
the times
now pick up on the point that alex was
making just before the break about
boris johnson dividing opinion but in
the times he's eyeing up a decade in
power
yeah i mean we can't foresee the future
but we can expect i think
that he will certainly win another
election on this basis you know
the the 2019 election which secured him
that sort of almost surprise
80 majority in a way labor has recovered
a tiny bit of that tonight they're
saying
that the swing is kind of between two
and three percent from the conservatives
to labor
but we need to see far more than that if
the labour party which of course
has been basically still ousted from
scotland has any chance of winning
a majority um and and if
boris johnson has this magic which the
conservatives have been seeking you know
george osborne said the conservative
strategy was to go after north theresa
may said the conservative strategy
was to go after the north it's only
boris johnson who's been
able to pull it off so whether you like
him or not
how what is the pathway for him not
spending a decade in power i think
that's what
people who would like him to lose need
to
you know start thinking about and alex
we must talk about scotland
uh potentially constitutionally highly
significant so far looking good for
nicola sturgeon
but according to the telegraph the pm
will not grant her her scottish
referendum
yes because in the end it's up to the
westminster parliament
to um to allow a referendum to take
place in part of our
country that would be legally binding or
not and it's for the prime minister and
the government of the day to make that
decision
and in the end i think boris johnson
whatever his merits or demerits would
run terrified of being the prime
minister who oversaw the breakup of the
united kingdom
so i entirely understand the position
that he's taken here
and he's seized a moment of of real high
watermark political support in order to
express it he might if he wants to go on
and think about the next things
and legacy and so forth think about
other constitutional issues first and
foremost getting the boundary changes
through that mean that
future elections fought on fairer um uh
guidelines than the ones that we've been
fighting of late which are pretty skewed
but first and foremost keeping the union
together has got to be number one on the
job statement of any prime minister
but if polly there is a pro-independence
majority in scotland which looks likely
then the people have spoken it's not
about boris johnson granting a
referendum or not it's
the will of the people having their say
yeah i think it's difficult to continue
withholding consent for a referendum but
we did have one
pretty recently and you know brexit is
still
kind of whilst obviously it's happened
there's still lots of kind of
transitional experiences that we're
going through to settle you know
trade uh negotiations i think for
scotland
to make that decision before really the
duster settled around brexit would be
a mistake because it is still a kind of
ongoing constitutional challenges there
but you know a boris johnson in my view
hasn't prioritized the union enough
because
he put a sea border down the rc and we
know that we are in a mess in northern
ireland
with um you know again constitutional
difficulties there because
he's been cavalier okay polly alex
thanks very much
indeed